this is a production of Cornell
University
thanks for having me I really appreciate
chance to come up here I've been
enjoying the last couple years I've been
collaborating a bunch with the Ryan lab
and so that's been a lot of fun and a
lot of interesting research thrusts and
and so today's talk is to give you a
little bit of a taste of some of the
work we're doing in beltsville
particularly in the development of high
residue no-till grain production systems
will give you a taste of what's going on
down there try to link it to some of the
things that are going on up here reality
is obviously we have some climatic
differences so I have a little more
flexibility in Maryland with some of the
work we do with corn particularly so
that's kind of why a focused on corn was
because I think that'd be a little bit
something new for you guys in this
department these high residue new till
corn production systems where I take it
you probably hear a lot about soybeans
so this is an ambitious title and like
in every ambitious title not everything
and the title might be in the
presentation so there's a few little
missing details just because I wanted to
kind of cover wide swath of things so so
you know not everything in the talk is
going to cover conventional and organic
in fact most of it is going to be around
conventional systems on I'll try to make
some linkages to the implications and
organic as well so this is really what's
been driving conservation for so long
now right the Dust Bowl came and since
then there's been just a suite of
various different strategies in
agriculture to to conserve soil
resources and this is an ongoing
dialogue for some time now certainly
no-till agriculture has been one of the
dominant strategies to address soil
erosion and and and and to conserve
those soil resources organic agriculture
has its own paradigm in which it tries
to address soil conservation in the
building of soil health as well and and
so there's this kind of linkage between
these two systems in that they're both
very soil centric and soil management
centric no-till being this Cadillac in
reducing erosion from the standpoint of
you know improving you know water
infiltration increasing us all organic
matter again reducing the erosion and
obviously why one of the reason
this is taking off so dramatically and
this is just a distribution of no-till
ground in the country and this is thirty
percent for the mid-south so this is
thirty percent and these regions here
are twenty five to thirty percent reason
this is taken off so rapidly is because
farmers can dramatically save the amount
of time they met a labor they can cover
fields really rapidly with machinery
they're not you know they're not running
machinery through the soil and so that's
certainly been a huge advantage but
there's there's a challenges associated
with no-till agriculture if you look at
this this map here this is a map of
herbicide resistance you know so this is
particularly glyphosate resistant
species across the US and well in
actually part of Canada and if you look
this tracks pretty closely to the areas
that are dominated by no-till
agriculture right so so there's this
paradox in our management between
practices that really conserve our soil
resources with practices that result in
some new challenges and some new
management constraints and so while
we're really excited what we can do with
no-till agriculture herbicide resistance
for example has really challenged our
current world view when it comes to
no-till agriculture and so how do we
address that and and and and and look at
you can just see the rise over the years
and they might have unique cases of
herbicide resistance so it's it's a it's
a real issue for conventional
agriculture and then the state of work
in organic agriculture weeds are also a
real problem in that system and and
particularly as organic producers who
historically have not been reduced
tiller no-till start to try to reduce
chillage in their systems we need to
become even more problematic so weeds
really are at the center of this
challenging and conserving soil
resources and both of these types of
systems so the typical approach right is
to diversify our chemistry stack genes
that's kind of historically how we try
to address resistance and that's
certainly a very important aspect of
weed control and moving forward with
herbicide resistance issues but there's
other strategies there's a lot of folks
emphasizing integrated weed management
practices and this is by no means a
laundry list but it gives you a
sample of the types of practices that we
target to it both address we concerns in
the system while trying to conserve some
of these practices like no-till
agriculture and so the remainder of my
talk is really going to focus on these
types of practices and how we can
particularly manipulate cover crops in
the system to you know enable us to
continue towards these these goals with
sole conservation and no-till
agriculture of course no talk would be
complete without mentioning cover crops
without going through all the list of
services that they provide certainly not
a laundry list but there's a wide range
of services to cover crops provide their
multifunctional tools and that's why
they fit well into kind of these no-till
systems or as a way of kind of helping
to inhibit or suppress weeds as well as
provide another number of services in
the system so this is what we've been
focusing on for a number of years and
when I say we really this has been a
collective effort for some time now
folks throughout the whole mid-atlantic
and northeast region have had a really
great synergy and interactions and the
development of these high residue
no-till systems many folks at Cornell
have been key players and this certainly
I know a big influence to everything
I've done in these systems and all the
work that we've done over the years have
really come from Chuck's early work with
John Teasdale and all of those questions
they asked related to how different
mulch elements suppress weeds and so
what you're seeing now is kind of where
we've been taking that work and how
we've been trying to operationalize that
into production grain production systems
and so we've been historically using a
lot of rye and soybean systems and hairy
vetch and corn this varies there's a lot
of interest in other cereals and other
legumes for a number of reasons but I'm
going to just focus on these these two
cover crops today and looking at them as
in mono culture and a mixture most of
you are probably familiar with this
piece of equipment at this point by now
and this is simply a tool that has
helped really operationalize our ability
to do hi residue no tell production
systems with cover crops because it's a
way of wrapping
knocking down cover crops and enabling
us to plant cash crops behind that and
whether or not you're spraying your
cover crop and then rolling it down to
make a mulch that suppresses weeds or
whether you're killing it effectively
with the roller crimper in an organic
system both have the same implications
in the standpoint of creating this this
uniform mulch mat and this just gives
you a taste of what some of this looks
like and and and the kind of residues
that we're working with so what I'd like
to first do is talk a little bit about
the equipment end of things that's
really where a lot of the learning has
been over the last decade we've
implemented a host of biological studies
looking at interactions between weeds
and cover crops and cover crops and
fertility management but one of the the
constraints it's really made it
difficult for us to take this from
something that we're evaluating on a
research station to recommending to
producers is our ability to get uniform
populations of our crops in the field
and regardless of the conditions of the
cover crop and so I'm just going to
briefly review some of those approaches
so we certainly find planters to be much
more effective than drills you have less
steel that's going through the field and
so you can get better downward pressure
and and the planter certainly has better
singulation of seed and placement of
that seed and so that's been a big step
forward for us we're early years we're
focusing on with drills particularly
with soybeans soil moisture content and
weight is a huge component of the
efficacy of our ability to cut residue
and get seed into the ground and so
that's something that we've booked at a
lot over the years when the residues
used to wet sometimes it's hard to cut
and it can get pushed down into the
ground and that particularly applies to
the soil if the soil is is really wet
then it's not firm enough to provide
that resistance to get good cutting
action with our Coulter's and so there
we don't get good cutting of the residue
when you don't cut the residue the
plants are just rides up on the ground
and you deliver a nice row of seeds all
along the surface of the ground and you
don't get your crop so this is a real
big issue residue quality I just
mentioned a little bit about that so
we've been
playing a lot with timing of rolling
with timing of planting and the
combinations of those practices I'm not
really going to focus a lot on that in
this talk but we have a number of papers
over the years that have come out to it
that have addressed that issue and we
feel like we have a better handle now on
just the the interaction between when we
kill and when we plant and what the
residue quality needs to be and what the
soil conditions need to be Colter types
generally we've been focusing mostly
with on using these type of ripple or
bubble Coulter's anything that has a
wavy fluted edge on it just creates more
surface area to go through that residue
and more cutting action that has to
occur and so there haven't been really
effective folks like these different
bubble or Ripper ripple or straight
cultures for various reasons due to soil
texture and and and what they're doing
in their individual operations but
generally you want a straight edge on
that end to get good cutting closing
wheels have been another another issue
that we've dealt with over the years and
what we're moving towards is more of
these curved tines coupled with like
either cast iron or rubber discs because
we get not only better closure but you
get some crumbling more of the soils so
that you get more seed to soil contact
so that's kind of the name of the game
in this right is is both being able to
cut through the residue that's goal one
and then after you cut through that
residue being able to get good firming
and seed so contact around your crop
seed and so these are some of the new
planters now that we are we're working
with we're working with planters that
have trash wheels like these shark tooth
out the front to either totally remove
or just partially remove the residues in
the front of these Coulter's and then we
have these heavy residue slicers that
come in behind that to cut that residue
to make sure that it's clean and then we
let the normal planter configurations
which is back here do their usual work
and they're not dealing with the same
amount of residue as these front units
are and so we basically add another tool
bar in front of our planter just to
address these issues
okay enough with the machinery talk I'm
not a nag engineer so I don't have a lot
more to say about that that's some of
the discoveries that we've had over the
years we're going to talk a bit more
about biology and and particularly focus
on managing cover crops for improving
the persistence of the residues that we
have out there and for better weed
suppression and then trying to improve
our nutrient management and that's
really been the challenge in corn with
soybeans we're all focused on just
getting big cereals out there so that we
can suppress a lot of weeds and we have
a fixing nitrogen fixing cash crop so
nitrogen isn't isn't an issue for us
really when we're balancing both
nitrogen and weeds in these systems
regardless of whether they're
conventional or organic that's when it
becomes a bit more challenging and so
that's why there's been a lot of
interest in combining cover crops you
know you can get the benefits of grasses
which are highly lead suppressive they
don't produce a lot of nitrogen with
legumes that do produce a lot of
nitrogen but are not as we suppressive
and so the focus on combining these into
mixtures and trying to identify what are
these optimal configurations depending
on your production your production goals
is is a big part of getting optimal
performance out of our cover crops and
having a consistency from year to year
so these are the themes that I think are
important to cover from your ideal cover
crop mixture for no-till corn right we
want something that is going to produce
a lot of biomass so both it has the
potential for suppressing weeds but that
it also produces a lot of biomass in
which translates into more nitrogen
content that it you know slow residue
decay which also translates into better
synchrony of the release of that
nitrogen with crop uptake and so I'm
going to kind of cover these different
themes now in the next set of slides so
this is an experiment which we establish
in we've have about four years of this
experiment and we've conducted this and
where it's done now or not it's it we
just finished it last year and we did
this on to replicated sites that have
fairly similar soil types we did this on
a certified organic field that's been
certified organic since 2000
and we did it on a site that receives a
lot of the kinds of diverse amendments
and and cover crop practicing I'm has
similar crop rotations but is managed
conventionally so they have a lot of
similarities in their management history
the commodities that are in those
systems I got corn soybean wheat
rotation and and in this and this uh in
these two sites we created essentially
at a continuum of cover crop mixture
proportions so here is our our cover
crop mixture proportions from a 0% vetch
all the way to 100% bench and vice versa
the hundred percent yeah so I'm sorry
doing that wrong here so this is one
hundred percent vetch and this is one
hundred percent rye and these are just a
replacement series design based on
maximum seeding rates of the
monocultures and so first let's look at
some of the biomass so here we these are
collected in half meter squared frames
and they were there collected actually
in every single fertility treatment
which I haven't described yet so there's
a whole host of fertility treatments
layered on top of this and we took cover
crop data for every one of those points
so our biomass that you're looking at
right now is a tremendous amount of
samples that are in those because the
fertility treatments haven't been
imposed yet because we haven't killed
the cover crop yeah it's but would so
run we're taking that biomass samples we
have a quite a bit of data that goes
into these figures and so what I want to
introduce you to is just a simple
replacement series design where you're
looking at in this case a hairy vetch
surreal rice-eating rates so these are
our categorical treatments these are
actual just treatments that we imposed
out there and you're moving from zero to
one hundred percent vet and you can see
here here's the veg going up here's the
rye going up this direction and this is
the total biomass so we're going to look
at this in a little bit more that was
exactly what I shouldn't do there we go
so this is a model that has had a lot of
use over the years to look at plant
interactions and plant competition it's
a dewitt model if you want more details
about this model you can look here I'm
not going to go into every aspect the
nuance of this model but just
conveying that essentially you're
looking at how these species perform in
mono culture as compared to the how they
behave in mixture and then the
interactions of those across these
different seating rates and then the
total model represents the addition of
these two independent models so again
vetches going up rye is going to the
left and this is our monoculture biomass
of rye and this is our monoculture
biomass of etch and this solid line
represents total biomass one of the
reasons folks use this kind of design is
because it is a useful way for looking
at over yielding so do the combination
of these two cover crops produce more
biomass than the sum of the parts so to
speak and and so there's a lot of
interest in over yielding for a number
of reasons and like such as in poly
cultures intercropping systems and in
this case we're looking at it in the
case of cover crop performance and so
now all I've done is just taking that
one figure and show you the extent of
the datasets we have so this is the
North farm are organic site which tend
to have much higher soil fertility or at
least typically does then the south farm
which again similar soil types but one
is conventional one is organic and what
you're looking at here are three site
years of data done we're both of these
different cover crops were established
about very similar time frame in fuels
that are not very far apart so climate
is not very different between these
fields but what I really want to q into
is just look at how strikingly different
the behavior of the species are we're
like for example here where hairy vetch
is not very competitive early on and
there's a real lag and rye is extremely
competitive and dominates compared to a
system like this where vetch is
increasing biomass rapidly so there's a
lot of factors that go into cover crop
performance and I think you know there's
a lot of things we can we can talk about
this figure the key points here just
that where these plus signs are where
years where we saw over yielding but
what I really want you to q into is just
how much variability there is in these
six site years and there's a lot of
factors that go into cover crop
formats and when we're trying to get
producers to use cover crops you know a
big issue with using cover crops is the
consistency and precision in which you
can use these cover crops in your
production system and so part of using
mixtures is a way of kind of reducing
some of that variability because of the
plasticity of the two species but even
within just these two species you can
just see on sites that tend to have a
little bit more nitrogen for example
such as as these fields here where the
Rye really dominated versus sites that
were a lower nitrogen levels you can see
big differences in just the growth rates
of the individual species now we're
taking this same set of samples and
we're analyzing it for in nitrogen
content and so this is just one of those
many site yours that we're just looking
at and now we're looking at total end
content we're looking at end content in
the veg and end content to the raw and
this is across this proportion gradient
but now whereas before we had
categorical treatments now we're using
the raw data whereas the biomass that we
actually harvested out in the field that
just because we put out an eighty twenty
percent mix of Ryan vetch doesn't mean
we ended up with exactly in eighty
twenty percent mix so this is the real
distribution of biomass in amongst those
species in the field and now let's kind
of look at this point here you can see
that and so this is monoculture legume
biomass and that's how much night I mean
nitrogen content not by Anna sorry so
this is how much nitrogen we can produce
with the legume and monoculture and what
I want you to look at is this region of
missing information so this isn't
missing information this is every year
we put out these different experiments
and some years vet biomass dominated
more and we were able to span that
region in other years we didn't and you
can see how much less veg biomass that
we had and the right ended dominate but
what you can see is generally despite
that at our fifty percent mixtures or
when we start to get above a certain
threshold we notice that this took a
solid line that's the total
nitrogen of the entire cover crop that
tends to be equivalent to your legume
biomass in monoculture am olivium
nitrogen content in monoculture so the
idea is you're trying to find that
threshold where the end content in your
mixture is equivalent to the end content
in your monoculture of your legale and
so when we look go back to this same set
of slides now here is the all six site
years in this data set as well as data
published data sets all over the country
we did a meta-analysis this was
presented at the last try society
meeting of mixtures versus monocultures
and the trends that we see both in our
data sets as well as across the
literature are some key points that I
think are worth mentioning one we
generally do see over yielding with
mixtures of grass legume cover crops
particularly in this case rye hairy
vetch so we do tend to get that greater
biomass production and mixture and that
generally when your legume is fifty
percent of the composition of the total
biomass and mixture that's when we get
to about that threshold in total end
content and so just there alone if we're
asking quite having more grass in the
mixture well depending on what you're
targeting whether your nitrogen needs or
weed needs you might want to find
yourself on a different part of this
trajectory based on your your management
objectives so that really will depend on
and give them farmer and so what we're
trying to do is just lay out the
spectrum of potential that's out there
and producers we have to make those
choices based on their needs and what
the major factors we found contributing
to that this over yielding are really
the proportion of the cover crop and
seeding rate applied and GDD and what
was really interesting most experiments
that have over yielding of cover crops
are not when they're doing a replacement
series like us where we're actually
decreasing the seeding rate of one
species for the rate of another a lot of
folks who are working with mixtures are
finding this over yield and where
they're having higher seeding rates then
what will be the equivalent of a
species seeding rate relative to the two
species so summary with those set of
figures that we looked at you can
achieve equivalent or greater biomass
than monocultures silly rule right ends
the dominate and our sites now maybe
that's because we're of a history of
manure management a history of cover
cropping and soil conservation and our
research sites that we have a little bit
higher mineral mineral end then if
you're going to some of your sandier
sites or lower fertile sites but
generally rye dominates because of that
excess nitrogen availability and again
what I mentioned about the plateau at
fifty percent hairy vetch biomass so now
we follow this up with a decomposition
study looking at the release of the
decay of that cover crop biomass as well
as the release of nitrogen into the soil
and so here we're using litter bags to
do that and these are the proportions we
targeted so slightly different before
we're looking at six different cover
crop mixtures we replace some of them
and just went to 25 75 s and 50 50 s
because it's a lot of work to do these
litter bag studies so I managers you an
exponential decay model many of you are
familiar with this this is one of the
most common models that we use in
agricultural sciences for those who are
not Q into both the P and the K because
those are the two coefficients that
really that were that we're going to be
talking about quite a bit this is
somewhat almost a double exponential so
for those of you not familiar the main
exponential model decay models right
here and this kind of allows for some
slower pool decay that I'm not going to
go into much discussion about that but
but just to give you a little taste or
folks have an understanding what they're
looking at here if you hold k constant
which is our decay rate and you very p
this is our pool size so the distance
the difference between these asymptotes
represent the pool size whether that's
the pool of nitrogen or the total amount
of biomass that was lost from the system
that's our pool size and so that's what
happens when you vary p when you're very
k that affects the shape of that decay
the rate of decay in this model and so
what the next set of models we look at
our you're going to see differences in P
and K and that's what's driving the
differences in the relationships
of these cover crop in their biomass
decomposition and then release so here
you're starting to get familiar with the
various different data sets we have here
this is the cereal rye at the top this
is hairy vetch at the bottom so this is
just a decrease in cereal rye and an
increase in hairy vetch as you go down
and as you'd expect as you increase
hairy vetch into the mixture you have a
faster decay rate or you have a greater
amount of decay that bat for that matter
and so what we were generally seeing is
an increase as you increase hairy vetch
proportion you have an increase in the
proportional lost and so that proportion
loss is P so that's just the total
amount of biomass in this case and
another slide will be the total amount
of nitrogen we also find that as you
increase hairy vetch proportion the view
have an increase in the rate of loss so
in this case you both have a rate at end
a pool size change in the decay of these
cover crops across these mixtures and we
have a fair amount of variability as you
expect from year to year and this this
kind of work we're actually working with
the adapt end folks and Jeff melkonian
on on calibrating some of the models use
and adapt tend to estimate nitrogen
released an uptake and so this is the
kind of issue that we have to address
that there's just annual variations
right that this this year you had out
faster rates of decay than this year and
as you might expect there were
differences and precipitation that year
so we had just it was just a little bit
more moist out there cover crops decay
better when they're wet then when
they're dry and and so being able to
build models that incorporate this type
of variability is important so that we
can make models that would be able to
extend across broad regions and useful
for estimating and release okay now
we're going to look at synchrony of
release with crop demand how are we
doing timewise
okay good alright great so now we've
looked at how cover crop composition
effects biomass the nitrogen content and
even it's it's a decomposition of the
biomass now we're going to look at some
of the nitrogen dynamics so one of the
reasons why we're so interested in
release rates and decomposition of cover
crops and how we manage cover crops may
influence those rates is because we're
trying to increase our use efficiency of
nutrients in our system generally all
any good you know sustainable and
conservative corn management system is
going to target trying to improve
nitrogen use efficiency so the amount of
nitrogen you put out in the landscape
you recapture as much as that as
possible back into that cash crop and so
in the case of corn you can see when it
starts to reach exponential uptake of
nitrogen that happens around at the 5v
eight and so that's why we have a
standard practice in conventional
agriculture to side dress our corn and
split our applications amongst nitrogen
put down at starter versus at side dress
so that we're not dumping all our
nitrogen out in the field when there's
nothing to take it up and and and we
lose a lot of that nitrogen early in the
season and what's interesting is that
you know we always so focused on good
synchrony of n with with our crop uptake
from mineral fertilizers standpoint but
we're really under state how much
available nitrogen comes from a legume
from the moment that it'sit's terminated
it releases nitrogen very rapidly and we
have lots of nitrogen leaching concerns
and potential coming from the legume so
that's why these mixtures really provide
a lot of opportunity to manage that and
so here again you're looking at you
don't rhyaz not modeled here because we
couldn't fit a model to that because it
really was no change in and and that an
activity book a combination of and not
no loss of nitrogen or what's more
common happen is is not only are you
losing some nitrogen from the Rye buttry
is also a sink for fungal mediated
nitrogen translocation from the soil
into the mulch above the
and so the nitrogen somewhat cycling and
stored but you can see between two
thousand twelve and thirteen while we
did have some differences the big thing
that stands out obviously is that the
rate of release of nitrogen is really
rapid in these monocultures and that as
we add grass into this mix we delay the
release of that nitrogen now we're not
just delaying the release of that
nitrogen we're also doing something else
where we're decreasing the pool size
right so that these this this is this
writ is our decay constant but this is
our pool size and so while we're slowing
down the release of nitrogen to get
better synchrony we're reducing how much
nitrogen that's going to the cash crop
which poses a management challenge right
because we want to hit our yields goal
and make sure we have enough nitrogen
out there in this case though increasing
hairy vetch proportion resulted in
increased proportion of n loss but
whenever we had a grass and Alou doom
together there was not much of a change
in the rate so the pool size differed
how much we total nitrogen was released
but the rate of release was was was calm
was similar and this is really just a
beautiful I just said so increasing
hairy vetch composition the mixture
resulted in a proportion of mass loss of
the P a proportion of n law so both that
began that P constant and then the rate
of mass loss during corn growing season
so that's just the biomass had a decay
rate difference but not so much in the
form of nitrogen release when legumes
were with grasses and mixture now this
is just a yield response from across the
mixture so this is no additional
fertility apply but you can see that we
can get almost ninety bushels difference
when going from a pure grass to a pure
legume and our corn green yields so the
cover crops are certainly providing a
huge impact on the performance of our
cash crop but as I mentioned before
particularly as we move towards mixtures
that have a lot of advantages were
reducing the amount of nitrogen in the
system and so we need more nitrogen this
can come in a range of different sources
for conventional producers mineral
fertilizers certainly the easiest option
of putting down
so uan is is some of the treatments we
do have in this experiment I'm not going
to highlight that a big issue in our
region as is in your region is animal
waste we deal with more poultry litter
than you guys you guys deal with dairy
but again that it's a big management
issue and so getting a manure into the
system to supplement the nitrogen needs
with with our cover crop it was one of
our objectives and and you can see here
that these are being surface apply when
we surface apply we lose a lot of our
nitrogen and in the form of volatilizes
and plus you also have some risk of our
ocean as well and so surface
applications is really you know been a
challenge to get past it's been decades
worth of research and effort by both
farmers and researchers to develop
technology to address that issue liquid
dairy manure has certainly seen the
fastest progression in that just because
it's easier to work with liquids Marilyn
this is really heightened for us because
we have more more restrictions coming
out for example we have to now have any
kind of animal waste incorporated within
48 hours of application so there's a lot
of interest in trying to incorporate
animal waste as a source of fertility
rather than applying it on the surface
or applying on the surface incorporating
through tillage just because of the
obvious concerns we expressed about
tillage and so these are some of the
prototypes that folks have developed
over the years to test this question
these are small plot units this can this
has been used in both pastures as well
as production systems mostly pre-plant
type of applications so we were kind of
excited about that you know it was it
seemed like some opportunity here people
are starting to work with poultry litter
these dry solids to get them
incorporated and so I kind of shopped
around and looked at some products that
might work for us we're not AG engineers
we're not interested in in developing
ready technology for farmers to adopt
we're biologists so we're going to test
how this behaves how we can increase use
efficiency of nutrients and and what are
the benefits of the system and hopefully
the AG engineers will figure this out
and make this work and I know that this
a challenge for a number of years so
this is this is by no means a piece of
machinery that's farm ready vegetable
ready yes this would work great in
vegetable systems but we're just working
with pelletized poultry litter because
pellets are are really easy to work with
they behave as far as decomposition
kinetics very identical practically to
to bulk litter and so from a behavioral
standpoint it's alessa test our
questions but we're able to put out very
precise uniform rates and we're able to
ban this poultry litter and the machine
we built allows us to apply it at side
dress so whether or not side dressing
poultry litter is going to become a
regularly adopted practice or the focus
is still going to be pre-plant there's
lots of logistical constraints actually
side dressing corn with poultry litter
than just coming in at planting and just
a lot of management issues but this is
we wanted to continue to test that
question of use efficiency where we're
side dressing our poultry litter and
take advantage of the types of
management practices we know work with
with mineral fertilizers and so this is
what that looks like here we've got
Coulter cutting a trench that's slightly
skewed it's on an angle and so it
creates a little trench as it drives to
the field and poultry litter shot right
down into that trench and then these
closing wheels close that up and I kid
you not you walk into a field couple
weeks later you don't even know where
this unit went I mean the residue is all
covered up you can't see the disturbance
and you and you've just dropped down we
can drop down up up you know anywhere
from three quarters to know five or six
tons of poultry litter in an application
at this machine so this generated
several research questions that link to
this these cover crop mixtures that that
I'm going to present on and so some of
the questions that came out of this is
just you know how does you know side
dressing this unit work and we can it
will it will it affect the decomposition
of the surface residues that we're
getting a lot of benefits from and and
how does it distribute it to the soil
profile and how does it behave over time
I'm only going to give you just a little
glimpse of this work we had a lot of
work testing this question across the
suite of different management treatments
we're only going to look at a very
subset of them so now this is the
additional methodology but we're only
target
a specific cover crops or just the
monocultures and the mixture and we put
down poultry litter of various different
application methods where we broadcasted
on the surface and it where which is a
typical practice historically or just
put your pull trailer right over that
cover crop or apply it over the surface
incorporate it and manage like a tillage
based system organic site we managed it
organically as you would tillage the
conventional was just a chisel till
conventional tillage based system and
then we have all these subsurface banded
treatments where we put subsurface
banding at different rates and and then
we have a no manure application and so
I'm going to talk about a little
business if you have more questions
about some of the treatments that I
mentioned here certainly approach me
later in the day so to understand just
how that nitrogen is being released and
you'll be able to quantify the
availability of nitrogen now we have
this whole spatial issue it got to deal
with we've taken a broadcast rate and we
narrowed it down to these little bands
so the types of questions you have to
ask related to how you would take a soil
sample and test the the release rates of
nitrogen and what is available became a
whole research thrust into itself it was
quite fun so here we actually are doing
depth structured spatial cores over the
growing season of corn to see how that
nitrogen is moving and so this is what a
core would look like this is the band
and these are the number soil cores that
we've taken across that band and then
you know this it's a mirror image to the
left and to the right of that band and
so then those are compiled together and
analyzed for inorganic nitrogen content
and then also we segmented these into
these different depths so we have a
pretty good resolution of nitrogen in
that soil profile and so then we
developed a spatial model to assess
nitrogen in moving from that band and so
that had to both incorporate the band
effect the cover crop effect and the
residual spatial dependence and I could
give a whole talk just on this model and
what we had to do so I'm going to just
be really quick this is a diffusion
model we're using Euclidean distances to
estimate a nitrogen across that spatial
profile
and and and this is what that model
looks like there's a fair number of
other steps involved in and in this
model to get to this point but this is a
pretty picture we want to look at to get
a sense of how nitrogen is behaving
spatially this is just one site year
this doesn't include all of the other
fertility treatments this is just the
poultry litter ban that went down at
side dress and that's our ride our hairy
vetch and that's our mixture so these
are just our three cover crops at five
different growth stages of corn and the
band is done at side dress so this is
just the effects of the cover crop and
then as you see over time the movement
of the nitrogen away from that band and
what I think is the most startling from
our results the nitrogen doesn't move
very much that doesn't move very much at
all we're expecting all sorts of issues
related to vertical and horizontal
movement that we would have to build
into these spatial models the reality of
it is is that a lot of this nitrogen is
becoming available when the corn is
starting to grow rapidly and we see
tremendous root proliferation around the
band and so the nitrogen is actually
being taken up almost as rapidly as it's
being mineralized from that poultry
litter band and so you're seeing very
little movement away from the band and
what's more just coming back to that
other figure now what was really
interesting is that we saw no difference
from subsurface banding versus you know
no poultry litter whatsoever on the
effects of cover crop decay so not only
are we getting very localized nitrogen
when we banned that poultry litter and
and and not a lot of movement from the
band but we're getting no impacts on the
decay of our cover crops on the surface
and that's really important because when
we're trying to manage our system and
we're trying to know what our variables
are more interactions we have with our
management the more challenging it is to
make decisions so being able to know
what's going on with the nitrogen in the
soil and know that that's not having
that same implications on nitrogen or
mulch 2k allows us to make more precise
recommendations or farmers to make
better decisions about their management
so summary of these findings surface
banded pole trailer
did not affect decomposition as i
mentioned in fact all of this is really
just a review of what I just said so I'm
going to just give you another little
taste of some of the Supplemental work
we did around this this is just one more
piece of data so on top of all this
we've created these this continuum of
cover crops and nitrogen availability
and and and nitrogen source in the
landscape we you know we have all these
different mineral sources and manure
sources and cover crops so we know that
that has a lot of implications on n2o
emissions coming from the soil and and
and and certainly corn is one of our
biggest players and n2o emissions so
it's it's certainly an important place
to test this question and so I didn't
really realize what I was getting into
when we started this research but a
greenhouse gas measurements in it and 20
is quite labor-intensive and exhausting
and most of the expertise that was
involved in guiding my graduate student
and myself is coming from Michelle
cabbage le who has been doing kind of
greenhouse gas emissions in beltsville
for a very long time so here are the
frames that we use that they span the
distance from corn row to cornrow and
this is just an example of a sampling
event we do this year round any time it
rains or out there whether it's Friday
Saturday Sunday whatever they of the
week it is holidays if it rains we're
out there the next day sampling because
that's what's driving and 20 missions
and so just to give you a little taste
of what that looks like so now what
you're looking at is different rates of
poultry litter applied and and so this
is our tillage treatment so this is and
this these rates just to kind of cue you
in this is what we consider our P base
rate so kind of nitrogen applied at the
P removal level and then this one 135 is
really our nitrogen typical nitrogen
base rate and then this is rates that we
apply that are actually not untypical in
the delmarva at all but but it
represents our kind of our saturated
nitrogen levels so we're for either a
very low fertile site or just to help us
you know have an asymptote in the in the
sets that we're looking at and then this
9 kilograms is just because in the in
some of these organic systems were
actually been experimenting with just
putting down some pellets at planting so
we're actually running the fertilizer
boxes the dry fertilizer box is open and
dropping pelletized poultry litter at
planting and we're getting about 500
pounds of poultry allure put down at
that point that kind of gives you a
rough equivalent of the plant available
nitrogen that's coming so this is a
nitrogen gradient here of application
rate and this is just uh this is
basically no till and this is till and
what we also have in there is our bare
ground and then of course across this
axis is our bare ground awry our mixture
and our hairy vetch this is a this is
pooled for two years so we didn't have a
year interaction this is to complete
years of greenhouse gas measurements
measured I mean sometimes you know on
the upwards of 90 to 120 measurements in
a year and so this is a fairly
comprehensive look at how our fertility
and our cover crop management drives
greenhouse gases and clearly the things
that stand out obviously is that you
have more nitrogen system you're going
to get more than 20 emissions that's not
rocket science what should be
interesting to you is that the bare
ground really comes down as the as
having the least n2o emissions and
there's a number of reasons obviously
there's there's not some of the presence
of carbon coming from sources of cover
crops carbon is a very important
component of n2o release and creating
conditions for and into a production but
then also you're the soil dries out
quite a bit more you know when you'll
have a cover crop on the surface you
retain soil moisture levels much higher
which are more conducive and conditions
environment for greenhouse gas emissions
but what was really interesting was that
when you look at the amount of nitrogen
applied in the form of poultry litter
with the amount of nitrogen losses n2o
while sure the bare ground has its
advantages from from from the standpoint
of lower n2o but there's also other
implications of having you know ground
that dries out and and not having those
hartmann amendments going back in but
clearly the mixtures shine we get a
cover crop that can both supply the
nitrogens we need for the cash crop it
has a slower release rate and it also
reduces our n2o emissions as a function
of fertilizer apply so again cover crops
can increase in 20 missions generally
they respond in an exponential way
although you were looking at
log-transformed datasets and have some
you know future plans of following up
some of this work in these systems some
additional measurements you only caught
a little glimmer of these datasets and
and what we're kind of pulling together
and so kind of the next phase of this is
to kind of do some multi criteria
assessments of these systems looking at
the various different factors and how
they interact and kind of building a
more complete day set and also part of
the work that we're doing here is
working closely with Jeff in some of the
models that he's developing and that's
been a really fun collaboration
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu